start a detailed idea about three years
ago and three of us are very
enthusiastic about that's no audio we
just thought we wanted to build the best
product that we could we started to
develop the product and came up with
what we have now we should we call the
answer detar the answer your phones I
actually built to the highest
specifications possible with the current
technology available and of course to
the best of our abilities we started
with a simple shape that we fit a lot of
ears comfortably then we provide a
comfortable few because having a good
feel is important to good sound the
things has to sound the way it is and
call it an altar as natural as possible
so that was the sound signature that we
tried to achieve the other little
features like a step at the end of the
plot we also decided to go with an over
the ear cable arrangement because we
found that it actually reduces table
noise or substantially this was some of
the challenges that we had to face
because of the angle of the nozzle and
that angle was essential because we
needed to have an ergonomic fit that was
comfortable for everybody basically
every facet of our design has a function
as a purpose so for us we have this
thing in the office that we call a bowl
yet transparent design bowl mix your
design stand out from the crowd it makes
you want to pick it up and try our
design philosophy was to make
complicated things as simple as possible
but having the absolute best components
to achieve the best sound possible to
win something like this is an honor it's
a privilege one of the things I like to
encourage young budding the industrial
designers is to never to be affecting
out of box do not be afraid to try
because it's true failures that we learn
and there's some of the most important
things about design
you